Guten Tag.
Wo ist der Arzt? Ah, guten Tag. Hallo.
Hallo. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Frau Kanne.
Ich bin als Ersten tätekia.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen an einem Nestgeschef durchführen.
Nach Kursumablauf würde ich nach Ihrer Personnischen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, guten Abend. Hallo. Ich habe leider Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden.
Was heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Vorname ist Sultan, Nachname Kanay.
Kanay? Ja.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ulrike.
Mein Nachname habe ich vergessen.
Florian.
Florian. Könnten Sie bitte langsam Ihren Namen und Vorname
langsam beschädtabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Ulrike. Ul, Richard Ida.
Karl Emil Ulrike. Ja.
Und Nachname ist Florian. Friedrich Ludwig.
Otto Richard. Anton Nordbrunn. Florian.
Frau Florian, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Erster, 10.
73.
Wie grossen Sie?
1,64 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Vielen zu vielen, Frau Doktor.
Ich glaube, ich habe im Moment 84 Kilo.
Was führt Sie für den Aufbau, Florian?
Ich habe seit 3, 4 Tagen Schmerzen am Oberbau.
Manchmal ist es mehr auf der linken Seite unterhalb der Rippen.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Sind die meisten plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die sind eher langsam aufgetreten.
Ich habe es nur in den Tagen, aber es ist viel stärker geworden.
Ist Ihnen dafür einen Auslöser aufgefallen?
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Es hat plötzlich angefangen.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass etwas Besonderes war.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder vorübergehend?
Zuerst waren sie nur noch ganz gering, ganz kurz.
Aber seit gestern ist es dauerhaft anhaltend.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie schmerzend?
Stischende, sichende, drückende, brennende?
Also brennend zum Teil, aber es ist eher so drückende Schmerzen.
Manchmal dumpf.
Manchmal zieht es zur linken Brustkorb.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich aufgebläht bin.
Wie viele Schmerzen sind da?
Wobei es nicht mehr gibt.
Es gibt nur 5 bis 6 Schmerzen.
Manchmal ist es 2 bis 3.
Aber jetzt, wie gestern, 5 bis 6.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen schon etwas Medikamente eingeläumt?
Nein, aber gestern war es schlimm.
Da habe ich einmal eine Paracetamol genommen.
Dann ist es etwas besser geworden, aber heute habe ich noch keine Tabletten genommen.
Weil ich zu Ihnen kommen wollte.
Schmialen die Schmerzen, wo hinaus?
Wie gesagt, in der Magen oder nach links, unterhalb der Rippenbogen.
Wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Im Mittellinie oder links?
Sowohl als auch schwierig.
Manchmal ist es mehr in der Mitte.
Manchmal habe ich es auf der linken Seite.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstarzt?
Mir ist aufgefallen, wenn ich auf Toilette gehe.
Entschuldigung, aber wenn ich Stuhlgang habe,
dass es danach ein bisschen besser wird und leichter wird.
Haben Sie Blähungen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Bauch aufgebläht ist.
Seit wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Seit drei, vier Tagen.
Ist Ihnen das übel?
Ganz leicht, ja.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, ich habe es bisher noch nicht erbrechen und nicht durchführen.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal zum Stuhlgang?
Das war gestern Abend.
Gestern Abend.
Haben Sie eine Parkveränderung im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Gestern war ein bisschen schwarz.
Heute war das normal, aber gestern war es einmalig schwarz.
Wann haben Sie letztes Mal gegessen?
Heute Morgen.
Ich habe ein leichtes Frühstück gehabt.
Was haben Sie gegessen?
Eine Scheibe Brot mit Käse.
Seit wann haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Seit drei, vier Tagen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich etwas schwach, Kraftlos.
Ich fühle mich etwas krank.
Haben Sie sonst gebeschwerten?
Mit dem Atmen und zu heiß?
Bisher noch nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masal?
Schüpfen Sie, brennen Sie sich?
Was erlassen klappt bisher eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Da habe ich jetzt keine Sorgen, nein.
Haben Sie einen Vorkurs im Umfall gehabt?
Nein, da war jetzt nichts vorgefallen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Mit dem Schlafen habe ich bis jetzt eigentlich keine Probleme gehabt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt, ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, also.
Ich hätte gerne ein bisschen abgenommen, aber das Gewicht ist eigentlich gleich geblieben.
Wie ernähren Sie sich in der Regel Petraechesen oder Gebraeichesen?
Ich würde mal sagen, ich ernähre mich normal.
Ich esse auch Fleisch, aber jetzt nicht so oft.
Ich achte schon darauf, dass es eine gesunde Ernährung ist.
Ich habe viel Gemüse, ich koche immer selber.
Ich trinke wenig und oft gar kein Alkohol.
Also ich denke, dass sie mich gesund ernähren.
Das freut mich.
Frau Florian, ist Ihre Regelmessung regelmäßig?
Nein, also da bin ich schon seit Jahren in der Menopause.
Seit wieviel Jahre?
Ich glaube fünf Jahre.
fünf Jahre?
Ja!
Gehen Sie zur Kontrolle regelmäßig beim Frauenarzt?
Nein, ich mag keine Ärzte, deswegen gehe ich sehr unregelmäßig.
Es ist schon lange her, dass ich beim Frauenarzt war.
Okay.
Haben Sie beschwerden mit den Gentallenorganen?
Nein, bisher habe ich keine Probleme gehabt.
Frau Florian, ich möchte wissen, über Gesundheit zu schützen,
sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Also ich war letztes Jahr bei meinem Hausarzt, der hat sich das angeschaut.
Und der meinte, die Impfungen sind komplett.
Sind Sie allererbisch gegen etwas Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie, gegen Penicillin bin ich allererbisch.
Also ich bekomme immer so einen Ausschlag, Luftnot, Herzrasen.
Es gibt einen Schmerzmedikament, wo ich auch etwas allererbisch bin.
Das war noch etwas mit Novalgien oder so ähnlich.
Wie reagieren Sie auf Novalgien?
Da geht es bei mir mit der Blutdruck sofort runter.
Können Sie alle Lebensmittel gut vertragen?
Mit dem Essen habe ich keine Probleme, da ist alles ganz okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen wie Blutdruckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie sonstige Medikamente bei Bedarf?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzmedikamente, aber sonst nicht.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, aber vor vielen Jahren hat man meinen Meniskus am rechten Knie gerissen.
Das hat man operiert, aber sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Wann war das?
Das sind so ungefähr zehn Jahre, ist das schon her.
Ich möchte wissen, Kurafologian über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie trinken keinen Alkohol.
Wie viel Zigaretten haben Sie pro Woche?
Am Tag, am Abend habe ich vielleicht eine Zigarette.
Sieben bis zehn Stück vielleicht in der Woche.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Das ist schon länger, seit 30 Jahren.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht, aber haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Rom, nein, damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Ich möchte wissen, Krankheiten, ihre Eltern, Leben ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter ist vor zwei Jahren schon verstorben.
Woran sind sie?
Woran ist sie gestorben?
Er hatte leider einen Schlaganfang.
Okay.
Ihrem Vater?
Der lebt, der wohnt alleine jetzt.
Er hat einen Bluthochdruck und Diabetes.
Er hat Probleme mit der Prostata, aber das weiß ich nicht.
Gutartige Probleme?
Ich glaube, gutartig.
Sonst wüsste ich, dass der nichts gesagt hat.
Nehmt ihr Vater in Zulin oder Medikamente gegen Diabetes?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Meine Mutter ist auch Lehrerin.
Wo arbeiten Sie?
Ich arbeite in der Grundschule.
Sind Sie mit der Arbeit zufrieden?
Ja, das macht mir sehr viel Freude, mit Kindern zu arbeiten.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin Medik.
Ich habe einen Partner gehabt, aber mit ihm haben wir uns getreten.
Haben Sie schon mal geheiratet?
Nein, war auch nicht nötig.
Von heirat halte ich nicht viel.
Heutzutage muss man das nicht.
Ich nehme allein.
Machen Sie regelmäßig sportliche Aktivitäten?
Ich versuche, die Woche zu joggen und etwas Yoga zu machen.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Ist es etwas Schlimmes?
Es ist so früh, die Diagnose festzustellen.
Ich vermute, Sie haben Probleme mit dem Magen.
Die Diagnose festzustellen, brauche ich ein paar Labor- und Bilgebende-Untersuchungen.
Sie wollen mir Blut abnehmen?
Ich mache noch ein paar Bilgebende-Untersuchungen.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Magen?
Haben Sie Brennende-Schmerzen?
Ich habe ein paar Tage ab und zu ein leichtes Sod-Brenn, aber davor habe ich nichts gehabt.
Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung in der Körpermärk?
Nein.
Ich komme Ihnen gleich zurück.
Ich habe eine Art Zimmel.
Vielen Dank, aber lassen Sie mich mit den Ich-Lange-Baten an.
Die Schmerzen nehmen Sie wieder zu.
Nein, das ist nicht so lange.
Ich habe eine Minute in der Rap.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie andere Fragen?
Hatten Sie so etwas?
Nein, noch nicht.
Träten Sie Beschwerden in Ruhe oder bei Belastung?
Wir sind jetzt immer da, unabhängig von Belastung.
Haben Sie Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen?
Nein, das habe ich genug.
Mein Job ist stressig, aber ich liebe den Job.
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist sehr sportlich und lebt sehr gesund.
Ich weiß, dass sie keine Erkrankungen haben.
Vielleicht zum Untersuchungsergebnis vom Bauch?
Können wir uns noch etwas anfangen?
Ich habe eine Information für die Ärztin.
Bei der Ausgultation vom Bauch hat man einen sehr geblähten Bauch.
Bei der Perkussion hört man eine Trommel.
Sehr viel Luft im Bauch.
Das kann man abklopfen.
Beim Drücken ist es im Epigastrium.
Auf dem gesappten Bauch ist es obikulär Schmerzen.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Frau Doktor, Sie wollten doch in eine Minute kommen.
Ja.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarst.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patientin, Frau Florian, vorstellen.
Sie haben Sicherheit für mich.
Für Sie haben wir doch immer Zeit.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie für ein Patient mitgebracht haben.
Frau Florian ist 50 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,84 m groß.
Frau Florian, Sie haben sich bei uns
für die 4 Tage aufgetreten.
Sie haben die Schmerzen, die Brüder, die Störungen,
die Sie mit der Ausgultation haben.
Sie haben die Schmerzen, die die Schmerzen haben.
Frau Florian, Sie haben die Schmerzen, die Sie mit der Ausgultation haben.
Sie haben die Schmerzen nach dem Stullgang vermindert.
Die Patientin lag über Meteorismus und leichte Neusea.
Die Fragen nach Emesis und Gerichtabnahme wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnesie ist unauffällig,
bis auf seit gestern bestehende in Apethas.
Auf Nachfrage gibt sie an,
lässt sie Schutul, war Melana, wie Melana
und die genakulabische Anamnesie ist unauffällig.
Seit 5 Jahren ist sie in Menopause.
Sie ist vollständig, sie ist allergisch gegen Penicillin
und darauf reagiert mit Anaphylaxie und Angeodeme.
Sie ist normal und reagiert auf Hypotension.
Sie ist rauf, aber sie riecht nicht so viel.
Sie ist seit 30 Jahren in Rauf.
Sie ist für die Erkrankung der Erkrankung
eine Hyperlipidämie bekannt.
Sie nimmt die Beidav parasitämol ein.
Vor 10 Jahren ist bei ihr eine Operation wegen rechten Menüse-Rüptür erfolgt.
In der Familienanamnesie ist es ein wenig schwer,
dass ihre Mutter an Apoplex gestorben ist
und die Vater an Arterelle Hypertone diabetisch zu tun.
Sie ist eine Prostatehyperpulazieleide.
Sie ist Lehrerin und arbeitet in einer Grundschule.
Sie hat keinen Partner.
Sie lebt alleine.
Sie macht als supportliche Aktivitäten,
Jogh und Yoga.
Sie hat eine Diagnose für ihren Ver kindness.
Sie hat eine Diagnose für ihre Außenrechte.
Sie hat eine ökostische Erkrankung.
Wie kommen Sie auf Sub-Ilios? Sie haben doch gesagt, sie hat Stuhlgang oder sie hat Stuhlgang und kann Wasser lassen?
Wir haben gesagt, aufbillen gehen und...
Ja, viel Luft, das stimmt.
Und dann kann ich an klopfen, Trommeln.
So eine Trommel hat sie, also es ist viel Luft im Bauch.
Okay, allein das. Nur um es halt zu schauen.
Eigentlich, ich kann mir nicht richtige Diagnose in meinem Kopf beschreiben.
Okay, welche Untersuchung, wenn brauchen Sie oder wollen Sie doch machen?
Ja, ich werde als die Patientin körperlich untersuchen.
Ich taste Ihren Bauch ab.
Und ich suche nach Abperspannung oder Uptolens.
Welche Apparative Diagnostik schlagen Sie vor?
Otraschach.
Okay, wenn Sie ein Ilios sehen wollen?
Ja, bei der Ilios würde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme ab dem Überblick.
Sehr gut. Und was erwarten Sie dort in der Röntgenaufnahme, wenn es ein Ilios ist?
Bei der Ilios erwarte ich eine Luftwasserseitschein.
Okay, stehende Luft, wenn Sie das glauben, oder?
Ein Ilios.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich erwarte dann ein Abdomen.
Was könnte man theoretisch noch machen?
Ich würde eine Apparative Diagnostik auf die Abdomenzionografie durchführen.
Und eventuell einen CT.
Ich habe noch eine Apparative Diagnostik.
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen denken Sie noch?
Ich habe noch eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Was ist am Oberbau noch?
Pancreas.
Ja, natürlich.
Hat sich irgendein Prozess in Pancreas.
Ja, akute Pancreatitis.
Pancreas Tumor.
Kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber die Schmerzcharakter passt nicht so an akute Pancreatitis.
Differenzialdiagnose, die müssen Sie daran denken.
Ich muss eine Mediakartinfarkt auszüchten.
Man muss auch immer an den Herzen denken.
Und mein Ulkos auszuschließen.
Das haben wir vergessen.
Eine Magenspiegel.
Eine Gastroskopie.
Ja, wunderbar.
Sehr gut.
Die Verdachtdiagnose, hat die Kollegen schon gesagt.
Eine Subilius ist ihre Verdachtdiagnose.
Und als weitere Diagnostik denken wir an ein Ulkosventrikoli.
Oder eine Gastriethis.
Eine akute Gastriethis.
Woran man auch immer denken muss, ist,
eine akute Appendicitis kann oft auch
ähnliche Beschwerden wie bei einer Gastriethis auslösen.
Also Oberbauchschmerzen, Blähungen usw.
So sollte man dabei auch immer an eine Appendicitis denken.
Die Symptome ist unklar.
Das ist richtig.
Aber die Diagnose, eine Appendicitis ist oft sehr schwierig.
Und die Symptome sind auch oft sehr schwierig.
Das stimmt ja.
Aber das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht, Frau Doktor.
Die Sprache ist sehr langsam überlegt.
Die Aussprache ist gut.
Sie reden verständlich und langsam.
Sehr gut.
Ich glaube, wenn Sie so in der Prüfung sind,
werden Sie die Prüfung sehr gut beenden.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist richtig.
Wir haben auch mal nachgeschauen.
Man macht einen Röntgen, man macht eine Diagnostik.
Man hat eine Diagnose, die ist ein Symptom.
Man kann auch sein.
Aber ich glaube, er ist weniger.
Die Patientin hat viel Luft.
Aber sie hat Stuhlgang regelmäßig.
Es kommt Stuhl.
Sie haben vergessen zu fragen, ob Luft weggeht.
Ob Winde abgehen heißt es dann.
Wünscht mich da jemand?
Im Moment geht es sehr schlecht.
Ob Winde abgehen bedeutet,
dass die Luft aus dem Darm rausgeht.
Gehen Winde ab.
Die Patientin sagt ja oder nein.
Winde gehen ab, aber wenig.
Flatulenz, sehr gut.
Aber das verstehen die Patienten manchmal nicht.
Wenn man sagt, haben sie Flatulenz, dann denken sie, was ist jetzt los?
Winde abgehen, das versteht auf jeder.